a bar tent frame standing among charred
ruins
a reminder of the horrible night four
weeks ago when abdul fattah al-darghim
lost his ten-year-old daughter
in the bitter cold his ten neighbors
were trying to light a homemade furnace
when the entire tent went up in flames
the fire spread very quickly there were
huge flames and a motorcycle and some
fuel exploded
all the tents caught fire my wife and
children were trapped inside
only five made it out
my sister yasmine tried to save our
mother and she pushed her out
she told her go i'll come out right
after you but yasmine got caught inside
and she died
their youngest daughter dala also
suffered severe burns
an aid organization brought the
one-year-old to turkey for medical
treatment
doctors have sent messages and videos
but the family is not allowed to visit
her
[Music]
the border with turkey is closed to
syrian refugees
the mother fatima can barely stand it
i hope so much that she'll come back
healthy but i saw the fire
i feel the worst
like these happen frequently in the
makeshift camps in northern idlib
tens of thousands of people are living
here in miserable conditions
they lack even basic necessities
latrines
food heating fuel and medical care
constant heavy rain has now made the
situation worth
people here were cut off from all
supplies for days
many tents were destroyed age
organizations have been doing their best
but are totally overwhelmed the
situation is made even worse by the
rampant coronavirus
the infection rate in italy province has
risen dramatically
we've done what we can and together with
other aid organizations and the white
helmets
we've tried to raise awareness about the
coronavirus
we've handed out masks and disinfectant
but
given the desperate situation it's not
enough
family are simply glad that the aid
organization has given them a new tent
some clothing and even a new furnace but
they hardly use it despite the code
they have no money for fuel and they are
terrified
of using it anyway
my children and i have a psychological
problem in the tent
we are afraid to light the furnace when
my husband isn't here
our children panic and start screaming
when they see fire
it's very very hard for us
when they fled the fighting and air
raids abdel fattah thought
they would only be here for a few days
but now it's been 14 months
and they are too afraid to go back home
to southern eclip
because the fighting rages on
well for more now i'm joined by bahia
srikam she's with the
syria response office of the norwegian
refugee council and she joins us from
beirut in lebanon thanks for being with
us how would you
assess the situation for refugees in
syria right now
the situation for refugees in syria is
terrible as the reportage
states very clearly in syria in general
we are
this year we are facing 9.
9.3 million people are facing
troubles or issues having food on their
plate every meal
so it means that and more than 80 of the
population
is living below poverty rates in
addition to that
you add the heavy rains you add the
pandemic the corvid 19 pandemic
and you add active conflict in some
areas
it it makes the situation for the
relations very very difficult and very
dire
one of the the refugees they have been
talking to lately was telling me that
the most difficult situation for him is
that him and his family don't have
not even have a toilet and he has been
in a camp for the past five years
so five years without a toilet i think
it's a
a huge bridge to their dignity and it's
something that shouldn't be
shouldn't exist are aid organizations
managing to get resources to these camps
because
the conditions as you describe are very
difficult
so we're managing to get aid to these
camps through
several modalities one of them and the
most important one
is the correct what we call the
cross-border resolution that is voted by
the u.n security council every
every year and we have to call for this
resolution to be renewed again in july
otherwise we will not have access to
these populations anymore
and the current access is already very
small
and the funding we have is important
but the needs are so huge because we are
talking
about more than half the population who
is
who needs humanitarian humanitarian
assistance
today so we need to make sure that
success is
permanent well in addition to basic
humanitarian assistance which the need
is
dire as you say what are what about the
pandemic because the coronavirus
pandemic is also
affecting that region what are the
chances chances that the displaced
people
in syria will have access to a
coronavirus vaccine this
year so this is also something that has
been
and is being discussed and negotiated
and we are trying to get the coronavirus
vaccine inside syria
and to provide it for all the
populations but to
ensure this access we need this
cross-border resolution to be renewed
like i was saying in july because it's
our only way to to be to be able to
access
those populations and we also need
everyone to step
in with more funding to make sure that
we we can provide the vaccine to all the
population in northwest syria but also
in the rest of the country
the other issue is while the vaccine is
coming
we need to make sure that we keep the
testing
ongoing that we we keep providing
the humanitarian workers with the with
all the
the hygiene kits they need to to be able
to do their work safely and to protect
the populations
right mr srikem thank you very much for
filling us in there that was
with the syria response office of the
norwegian refugee council
now let's look at some other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
uh
biontech pfizer have withdrawn a bid for
emergency authorization for their
vaccine in
india pfizer says it will resubmit the
bid with additional information required
by the indian regulator
the u.s has recorded over 40 000 virus
deaths in two weeks amid concerns that
cases could spike again
after gatherings for sunday's super bowl
mexico has run out of vaccine doses and
no new shipments are expected until the
middle of this month
with the hospital countries hospitals at
over 80
capacity there denmark says it will
launch a first
version of a coronavirus vaccination
passport by the end
of february